hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the russian chess championship
uh we mentioned in the previous video
that it will be uh well basically either
a karakin or a yanni pomnishi who wins
the russian chess championship
and nippon she uh drew his last game uh
to a maximum chicaive
uh and now we'll have to see what
happens in the game dubo versus kayaking
if kara kin uh gets a draw against duba
with the black pieces then he and nepo
go into tie breaks and if
uh kyra can by any chance wins with the
black pieces
then he is the winner of the russian
chess championship 2020.
so let's see what happens here uh as the
title suggests this is this is quite a
beauty
so double again with the white pieces
opens with e4
uh sorry about that uh we have e5 by
karyakin
uh and now knight to f3 we have knights
the c6 bishop to c for n the bishop the
c5
and i know what you're thinking the last
round of the russian championship 2020
uh you know we we definitely must play
the evans gambit here but
uh unfortunately it was not played in
this game however
however uh you'll see what happens we
have c3 so
the main line of the joko piano knight
to f6
and now d4 striking in the center e
captures on d4
and now the normal thing to do here is
just c captures on d4 this is the
absolute
top move here but we have b4 by duboff
so
uh on move six do both does go for b4
and we are going to call this the
delayed evans gambit
as it offers quite quite amazing play
for white so let's see what happens here
bishop back to b6 and now e5 challenging
the knight on f6
and now the problem is uh while usually
in positions like
these when white gives up the d4 pawn
plays e5 black will almost always play
d5 it's it's just the best thing to do
however the problem here with the
inclusion of b4 is that after captures
and capture you have this b5 move and
then it's uh
very very tricky to play this for black
especially if you uh if you don't have
this prepared and duba obviously does
have this prepared even though it's a
classical volume it's still super
complicated and you're going to burn a
lot of time to
you know figure out what happens here so
basically you're removing the knight
away from c6 the e5 square will not be
available to the knight the seven square
is not available you have to go all the
way back and then
it's just uh it's just very hard to play
this for black
so instead after e5 we have knights to
e4 by karakin
just keeping it simple and now bishop to
d5
attacking the knight here so knight
captures on c3
attacking the queen and now we have a
trade here captures captures and
now uh there is one game in the database
where castles was played
but here we have bishop to g5 by duboff
and it's already as of move tended we
have a completely new game
uh so of course uh the black queen is
under attack you need to block this
you do not want to play something like
f6 it just opens up the position too
much f6 bishop h4 and you're
you're never castling here anymore so
instead after bishop g5
knight to e7 and now uh
here we have castles by white and here
h6
challenging the bishop bishop to h4 and
now comes
finally castles by black and now okay
you don't want to lose your light square
bishop so bishop back to b3 but before
that uh
rook to e1 so uh the bishop still cannot
be captured due to this pin and
basically dubo is asking kayaking with
every move are you going to play
g5 and karakan reluctance to play it he
unpins he goes queen to e7
and now the bishop can finally be
captured so bishop back to b3
and if you look at this position uh
white is up in development
immensely but black is up to pawn so if
black
is able to uh you know make make
something out of those
two pawns and get his pieces developed
then black should of course have a
great advantage so here the immediate a5
saying okay
i i either capture here and then have a
uh
connected and the guarded past pawn here
on c3 and i get a semi-open file for my
rook
uh or you capture and then we just
continue the game but here comes
another great move by do of bishop to f6
and now it is just uh just a beautiful
uh move uh the
the bishop pair slicing all the way to
the king side of course you cannot
capture it because after pawn captures
you will not be able to move the knight
and it's just game over for black so
instead
after this bishop to f6 move with a4
now uh trying to get the bishop away
from this diagonal
we have bishop back to c4 and
now comes knight the uh knight to g6
finally the knight comes into play but
now queen to d3 again
do both moves with wit's tempo as now
the thread is just queen captures on g6
you cannot
capture with the f-pawn because the
f-pawn is pinned
uh you could capture on f6 but it's
again a very
uh uh i mean it's the same idea just
queen captures on g6 and white gets
checked made
king here captures here with checking
back queen to
uh e captures on f6 and now we see the
queen g7 checkmate or you lose the queen
or
both as you know it's impossible to
get away from checkmate here so after
queen d3 of course you have to do
something about this
so d5 now of course you cannot capture
because the
pawn blocks the bishop's path but here
comes
e catrice and d6 alpha song and bishop
to e6 now
karakan offers some material back to get
uh get his pieces developed but there's
a problem
of course duba doesn't go for something
like bishop captures on c3 or bishop
captures on e6
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this amazing move do we've played
here while i give you a couple of
seconds
uh so uh you know have at it
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on figuring out
that
it's actually the position from the
thumbnail and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
queen capture some g6 a beautiful queen
sacrifice and it seems it doesn't matter
that karakan blocked
the path uh since now there's not all
that much to be done here because if you
ignore the queen sacrifice you play
something you can't even
do anything if you play something like
bishop captures then queen captures and
g7 is
checkmate so the queen absolutely must
be accepted so
f captures on g6 and now comes rook
captures on g6
and here the problem is katakan's queen
is under attack and if the rook moves
then it's going to be a discovered
check so you have to be very careful
what you play here if queen d7 just
rookie 7
i discovered to check you win back the
queen and then you quickly win the game
so uh karakan plays the only good move
here for for black
and that is queen to f7 uh now
blocking blocking the path and here you
could still win the queen however if you
go for something like
rook to e4 to guard guard the bishop
here
then we would see g captures on f6
bishop captures rook captures and we
would get a disposition
where black is just better white doesn't
really have much
much to show for and it's uh well
it would be pointless to do this so do
both plays the absolute best move
bishop captures on c3 he gets the bishop
out of the way
next he wants the he wants to get his
rook to e7 and
get some pressure going towards the g7
pawn however it also means that black
gets to keep keep his queen so king
uh not king to h7 king the h8 uh moving
the king and then now comes uh
well you want to get your rook to e7 but
you also don't want to give up the light
square bishop
so first rook to e4 attacking the queen
by the bishop uh and now defending the
bishop with the rook
so the queen has to move and you cannot
keep your queen on this
diagonal so here queen to f5 is played
and
only now duvet goes rook to e7 and now
the g7 pawn is under attack and
not a lot for karakin to do here uh he
played rook to g8
he has to give up one of the rooks
bishop captures we have rook captures
ng8 and
now even d captures on c7 creating
a past pawn on c7 and for the moment yes
the rook is guarding that square but
that can easily change a move like rook
captures could easily end the game rook
characters queen comes into the game
of course uh not uh not while the queen
is covering the c8 square as well but
something to keep in mind with black so
queen to c2 putting pressure on the
bishop also if the bishop moves on
well not on some square that isn't best
then also there will be a double attack
on the c7 pawn
but there's not much to think about here
just bishop to e5 and now the pawn is
defended
twice so here bishop captures an f2 you
could also capture with the queen
although after king to h1 there's
no no good continuation here so instead
bishop captures an f2 with check king h1
and now bishop back forcing this rook to
remain here otherwise uh
rook and bishop otherwise you're going
to lose the c7 pawn
so h3 uh dubo makes some room for his
king and now
king to h7 and now uh rook to e1
bringing the rook into the game and now
the rooks are doubled uh
while when the bishop moves it's going
to be very hard for for black to hold
this so here
uh you have to be careful if you go for
the pawn try and create
a pass pawn uh sorry try try to grab one
of the white's pass pawns uh then comes
just bishop captures on g7 and there's
no way to hold this once you capture it
just
a queen gets into the game so after rook
to e1 you play
a3 this is what uh cardigan played and
now comes king to
h2 uh we have g5 creating some breeding
room for the king
but still knights the d4 attacking the
queen and preparing to bring a third
attacker to the g7 pawn
not a lot for kyra can do here we have
queen to c4 and now
knight to f5 and now with the triple
attack here
uh it's only a matter of time before the
position cracks we have queen captures
on b4
and now rook to c1 now the the
queening square is defended and uh not
not a lot for
uh for black to do here you could always
give up the bishop for the pawn but then
it's a
queen and rook against rook rook bishop
and knight and
this will fall so it's nothing nothing
to look forward to
so king g6 karakin uh loses uh
uses his last resort move to go after
the knight on f5
but uh dubo even encourages it so
rook captures on g7 and now if rook
captures of course you just bring the
queen into the game because the rook no
longer covers the c8 square
so instead we have king captures on f5
but now
rook captures on g8 and now of course
you are ready to bring the rook into the
game
so bishop captures on c7 one last try
bishop captures and now queen to b2
attacking the rook here
but we have rooked the c5 check king to
e4
and now just rook to d8 and it was in
this position that sergey karakin
resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh the king really has no
no good squares and even if you capture
the pawn is it just a very nice mate
into
rookie five check king f4 and rook to d4
checkmate the pawn covers the f3 square
and there is nowhere for you to go with
your king
uh so with this uh rook 28 move uh dubo
won the game and robbed uh karakin of
his chances of winning his first ever
russian championship
uh so uh it was really really crazy
karakin only needed a draw and maybe
that's why he played so
passively because he was uh he was
probably thinking okay i'm just gonna
hold and then if
duval pushes too hard i'm gonna punish
him uh because if like i said if he got
a draw then he would go into tie breaks
against the annie pognishi but
uh dubois completely mowed him over
with that uh delayed evans gambit and
yes we are calling it the delayed evans
you know uh so so do tell your friends
about that
uh so yeah this is uh the game not not
only
the the best game of this championship
uh but
also you know not gonna say the the best
game of the year but
that that whole performance by duo i'm
pretty sure it's so one of the
top five games played in in 2020 uh
we'll see what
the the official people uh think about
that
uh but yeah so uh that's the game i do
hope you guys enjoyed it we're gonna
check that move out one more time before
we end the video
so bishop g5 and then we have this
beauty here uh
there we go bishop here and now in slow
motion
let's just check it out queen comes and
then queen captures on g6
beautiful stuff uh so yeah uh once again
i do hope you guys enjoyed it we're
going to cover a few more games as
we haven't shown a single game by the
winner other than the one
the one he lost so we will show one game
that he actually won
i would like to thank casper clay cooler
cameron omar hill uh nelson
g uh avery and josh atkins and kalman d
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
coverage uh not the coverage but uh you
know a few more games maybe uh
by the winner himself checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens
in the chess world thank you i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day